now if you're asking me if I'm wearing
pants the answer's no I'm not wearing
any [ __ ] pants you should already
know this I don't I don't like you know
I want my ballsack to be free Oh what is
going on you sexy peaches of [ __ ] that's
a compliment and an insult see that
that's what we are that's one of the
worst jokes ever to me I'm gonna kill
myself
okay now for some reason whenever you
try to better yourself you ever noticed
that there are people always out there
to put you down now during this funny
fanfic grind one of the biggest things
that I chose to do was surround myself
around positive people who helped me get
to where I wanted to be now I'm gonna be
real with you before I started this
there was a good handful of folks that
thought that I could not do it you
[ __ ] and to them I say yeah in
my past I have told many people on
multiple occasions that I was going to
get sexy as hell and well yeah well here
we go in other words I was the boy that
cried but oh he said I remember after
high school I told all my friends after
I came back from college I was gonna
have a six-pack three girls and a
long-dead turned out I gained weight I
got dumped and my belly covered my penis
so you know I was I was almost there you
know just look I got dude people told me
something about the freshman 15 more
like freshman 50 [ __ ] you lied oh I
think I also told him that I would come
back looking like a Greek god and I
didn't lie I did I just came back as you
know the god of gluttony oh one burrito
at a time that didn't look like a
burrito like a fat dick coming to my
face when I gain all that weight my
favorite color was Green and that not
help my game at all you have any idea
how many kids came up to me asking me
for an autograph
mommy look it's Shrek oh I will kill you
now for me personally I never really
gave that people around me a reason to
believe in me because I didn't believe
in myself reason being was because what
I said were just words that didn't
really have any conviction so the
support was never going to be there
everybody's a little bit different there
are those of you out there that have
done this or can do it by yourself but
there are some of us who really need
that extra push and that's where your
community comes in now for me it was my
friends and family that really helped me
when I needed it the most and that
includes you guys my funny fat fit fan
so for those of you out there that are
having a hard time doing it by yourself
just try to find that positive group of
people now if you don't have that you
got me my [ __ ] all right people now
let's talk about a workout that work for
me now last week we talking about squats
this week we are gonna talk about
deadlifts wired deadness one of my
favorite workouts because once again it
works out a huge muscle group that helps
you lose a lot of weight Dennis if you
guys don't already know is targeted
towards the lower back but it does not
just work out your lower back it also
works out your legs because you gotta
bend down drag through your heels push
that [ __ ] up and it also tightens your
core so if you're a person who's a lazy
[ __ ] and doesn't like to workout
just one muscle at a time then lifts are
a good thing to do so once again I'm not
a personal trainer and do not come to me
and ask me advice on how to do this get
trained by somebody who knows what
they're doing now if you notice in this
vid that I put up there are a few
problems that I do have number one I
don't have a lot of ankle mobility
because I fractured it about two years
ago and I tore all the ligaments so I
can't really get down in there and dig
my heels in so for me it's more of like
a straight back deadlift instead another
thing that I heard if I breathe my grip
in a little closer to also helped out
too so I'll be trying that soon as well
so the workout this week is dead lifts
you hairy little butt holes and I will
see you guys next week but remember life
is always what you make it but is up to
you to take what you deserve let's go
for Brooke Oh what is going on YouTube
yes workout for this week was a deadlift
for you
deadlift that but anyways you guys
always ask about the shirts that Robin
is because I rock them from go-for-broke
apparel comm such as this right here
this one actually went out because you
guys didn't cut the fast enough but we
do have some other fresh designs that
have pretty dope to go in and check that
out
now remember funny fat bit fam I want
you guys to do this journey with me and
I want to be a part of your support
group so remember when you do
and you are continually doing this go to
your Instagram hashtag bunny Fitbit and
hashtag Davis oh comedy and I will go
ahead check out your pic like that
[ __ ] and maybe give you some
words of encouragement because you just
might need it like I do so family I will
see you guys this Sunday for another
vlog and of course Wednesday for another
funny fat bit and guess what in a couple
weeks we got a stupid-ass kick coming up
and I gotta tell you it's it's pretty
[ __ ] dumb yeah la vía Oh what is
going on you sexy peaches at the pump I
just spit at you Wow
now for some reason whenever you try to
better yourself you guys never noticed
that they were all about to get the boom
none of you guys have noticed whenever
you try to better yourself don't you
notice that I said notice a lot more
times than I should've
I'm chose to do was to surround myself
around positive people positive here huh
you know David sometimes do you got
you're gonna have to do one of these
without a blooper mm-hmm